[Musique]
image si les bleus ça c'est quelque
chose qui rend heureux pour moi d'amener
la clarté crainte qu'elles ne frappent
des recasements domine ce regard qui
illumine son visage
carole leblanc le doit à sa médecins une
huile sur toile de camille pissarro
devenue une prescription médicale
un prix madame leila ouaz or madame
leblanc elle vit avec la sclérose en
plaques
elle a eu deux cancers son bord d'un
quotidien c'est de dessiner tâche me
promène je m'arrête à quelques pas des
scènes entre excès une faire rentrer des
zones de compte bien parce qu'on aime ça
mais désormais ce sont les grands
peintres qui agiront comme médicament
complémentaires ça c'est la prescription
est alors sur la prescription c'est
écrit profité d'une visite gratuite au
musée pour vous faire du bien
seuls ceux qui sont membres de médecins
francophones du canada vers cette
prescription des grands bienfaits de
l'art thérapie c'est d'augmenter la
capacité d'adaptation de nos patients à
leur pathologie
après le sport pour être en santé ce
serait donc l'arle nouveaux guérisseurs
la fmq fait dans l'équipe d'énergie avec
pierre lavoie et puis nous avec madame
brand ils l'ont fait dans le cubisme ou
dans l'impressionnisme au choix
le patient est libre
l'entrée est valable pour 4 personnes
donc deux enfants offerte par le musée
des beaux-arts de montréal
c'est ça que ça donne la recette ça vous
permet de de pouvoir exprimer toutes
sortes d'émotions de pouvoir justement
les catalyser d'avoir cet effet
cathartique donc vis-à-vis de nos
propres douleurs et de pouvoir justement
communiqué la preuve avec carole devant
une fresque de waterloo
cantonné dans un environnement connaît
bien les moddeurs ce n'est plus facile
comme moi j'en ai parlé le plus en pagne
pas personne être dans un musée donc ça
permet de développer notre intelligence
sensible de pouvoir exprimer ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas oralisée ça s'éteint c'est
très important
elle espère que d'autres institutions
culturelles et d'autres médecins
emboîteront le pas l'écho en tout cas
est immense suscité tant d'intérêt
partout que ce soit en australie en
angleterre en france en italie
alors là vraiment je suis surprise reste
à mesurer les résultats auprès des
patients pendant toute l'année du projet
pilote moi quelqu'un qui ne désiraient
j'ai tout misé 10 rien trouvé de bombe
j'aimerais ça le rencontrer parce qu'il
n'y avait fermé ici mathieu prost radio
canada
[Musique]